c'est la famille d'ali ben on s'active
avant de démarrer la journée petit
déjeuner sino-canadien arrivé il ya deux
ans de shanghai les gours s'intègre très
bien chez isr et non ce n'est pas à
toronto vancouver montréal qu'ils ont
élu domicile
mais bien à charlottetown 2500
immigrants d'origine chinoise vivent sur
l'île du prince édouard soit un
immigrant sur cinq
c'est la proportion la plus élevée au
pays ce qui les attire les bonnes écoles
au calme et la nature et les chinois
pourraient être bien plus nombreux mais
beaucoup se découragent 80% d'entre eux
décident de partir vers les grands
centres pour obtenir de meilleurs
services d'intégration quand l'évêque
ali est en train de changer les choses
nous la suivons pendant une journée pour
voir comment ainsi prend en chine
l'école de mon fils était à 40 minutes
de voiture
aujourd'hui il peut marcher pour y aller
ça me motive à rester ici ali a plus de
temps elle peut se consacrer à l'outil
qu'il est dans sa mission son site
internet
djidji goût est entièrement mandarin
élimé toutes les informations
nécessaires sur les façons de faire de
l'île
c'est devenu le point de repère pour les
chinois allie aide à promouvoir les
nouvelles entreprises dirigées par les
chinois sur l'île
ce matin elle est celui ci à vendre ses
concombres de mer la femme d'affaires un
complice sont associés film you un agent
immobilier ancien directeur de
l'immigration pour la province
la communauté chinoise a explosé en 15
ans quand j'étais jeune il n'y avait que
quelques familles chinoises sur l'île
li est donc devenu agente immobilière
je me suis dit qu'en devenant en moi
même
immobilière je pourrais aider des gens
de ma communauté qui ne parlent pas
anglais 50% de leurs clients sont
chinois ensemble ils facilitent les
transactions sans infrastructures et une
communauté forte et bien établis comme à
montréal vancouver et toronto
l'adaptation est un peu plus difficile
mais là on est en train de bâtir une
communauté forte dans les années 90 la
population de l'île étaient en forte
décroissance
aujourd'hui c'est la province de
l'atlantique la plus prospère en termes
de croissance démographique et
économique
ils viennent avec des compétences
incroyable il contribue au développement
économique
plusieurs demandes des entreprises
embauchent du personnel et font de
l'importation et de l'exportation l'île
du prince édouard en profite
les entreprises chinoises pour sa vue
d'oeil il explique cette nouvelle
épicerie vient d'ouvrir comme celle ci
il y en a des dizaines dans la capitale
on y retrouve tout ce que les chinois
aiment et même des amis
en fin de journée ali assiste à
l'inauguration du centre de beauté de
nouveaux clients
ce sont des gens talentueux qui aime la
vie sur l'île alors s'ils peuvent faire
de l'argent ici ils voudront rester
c'est l'endroit idéal pour vous refaire
un look complet la journée est presque
terminée elle récupère fiston le petit
bonhomme a facilement d'opter lille et
sa mère s'assure cambon canadien il
apprend les deux langues officielles au
kenya l'île du prince édouard mise
beaucoup sur l'immigration pour assurer
son développement
maintenant que la communauté chinoise a
développé un modèle d'intégration les
autres communautés n'auront que le pont
à traverser pour venir s'installer ici
elisa sérère atouts canada charlottetown